[Musique]
on passe de 2 à 3 ans ce qui permet
d'obtenir le grade de licence et être
beaucoup plus conforme à l'enseignement
au niveau européen on augmente le nombre
de projets projet tutoré de façon à
améliorer
l'acquisition des compétences et enfin
on continue à avoir une forte
implication au sein des entreprises
puisque les étudiants du dut de propre à
ces stages allant de 22 à 26 semaines
sur lille 3e sur le site de vélizy ans
on a autour de vous des entreprises très
tournée vers le numérique et c'est le
cas des formations du site de vélizy on
a d'informatique du réseau des télécoms
génie électrique et des métiers de
multimédia et d'internet et donc on va
on va essayer d'avoir davantage
d'interaction avec ses entreprises pour
pour mieux coller aux profils au profil
attendu
en ce qui concerne peut-être vélizy en
juillet il ya 450 places à peu près à
peu près 450 places qui sont qui sont
offertes pour 7,9 rampe et on reste sur
les mêmes les mêmes flux que les années
passées avec le dignité